un grupo de voluntarios plantó árboles
en cinco parques diferentes plantaron 90
árboles en cada parque cuántos árboles
plantaron en total y bueno aquí está
todo lo que necesitamos primero nos
dicen que un grupo de voluntarios plantó
árboles en cinco parques diferentes eso
es lo primero que nos dicen porque
además nos dicen que plantaron 90
árboles en cada parque entonces si
queremos saber la cantidad total de
árboles que plantaron podemos resolver
esto de dos formas distintas
podemos decir que ellos plantaron 90
árboles en el primer parque ya esto
sumarle los otros 90 árboles que ellos
plantaron en el segundo parque y a esto
sumarle otros 90 árboles que ellos
plantaron en el tercer parque creo que
ya ves para dónde va todo esto a esto le
sumamos los otros 90 árboles que ellos
plantaron en el cuarto parque y por
último les voy a sumar los
y árboles que ellos plantaron en el
quinto parque bueno esta es una forma de
resolver esto sería sumar todas estas
veces 90 y lo podemos hacer nos va a
llevar un rato pero lo podemos obtener
ésa es una forma pero también podemos
decir lo siguiente podemos decir que el
grupo planto 90 árboles 90 árboles en 5
parques en 5 parques y entonces se va a
ver así 5 veces ellos plantaron 90
árboles entonces tengo 90 por 5 y vamos
a resolver esto de ambas formas vamos a
hacer ambas operaciones para llegar al
resultado y tal vez resolviendo lo de
ambas formas podamos llegar a la
conclusión de si existe una forma mejor
o más simple para hacerlo ahora bien
recuerda que 90 lo podemos escribir 90
lo podemos escribir como
a veces 10 lo voy a poner así 90 es lo
mismo que 9 veces 10 y esto nos va a
ayudar a sumar esto que tenemos acá
abajo porque si 90 es nueve veces diez
aquí tengo nueve veces diez más otras
nueve veces diez me da dieciocho veces
diez más otras nueve veces diez me dan
veintisiete meses diez más otras nueve
veces diez me dan 36 veces diez más
otras últimas nueve veces diez me va a
dar 45 veces diez o 450 observa que aquí
tenemos este cero de aquí lo cual
representa 45 veces 10 es decir estamos
hablando de veces 10 450 o 45 veces 10
es lo que plantó en total este grupo de
voluntarios ellos plantean un total 450
árboles
ahora pensemos en la forma de resolver
esto pero utilizando esta multiplicación
para esto recuerda que 90 es lo mismo
que 9 veces 10 entonces me quedaría 9
veces 10 y bueno a esto lo voy a
multiplicar por 5
entonces me queda 9 veces 10 por 5 o lo
que es lo mismo esto me va a dar bueno 5
por 9 es 45 45 veces 10 veces 10 y bueno
esto es exactamente lo mismo que 450 y
observa que estoy poniendo el 0 justo al
final entonces mi respuesta es 450 los
voluntarios plantaron 450 árboles y esto
lo obtuvimos ya sea sumando y
multiplicando ahora bien al menos para
mí la forma de resolver el problema por
una multiplicación me parece mucho más
sencilla y mucho más rápida
resolviendo estas sumas que tengo aquí a
mí me gusta más multiplicar pero de
ambas formas llegamos al resultado
correcto de 450 árboles